هذه علامات تشير الى انك ترضي الاخرين على
حسابك اولها الموافقه على اي طلبات
للاخرين باستمرار هذا قد يصل بك الى
الشعور بالارهاق او الاجهاد وايضا قد
يجعلك فريسه سهله لمن يدركون انك لا
تستطيع قول لا وبالتالي هذه علامه اخرى اي
انك ستصبح محاصرا بهؤلاء الذين
يستغلونك لحل مشاكلهم واحتياجاتهم وتحقيق
رغباتهم كذلك عندما تشعر بالاستياء بعد
مساعده الاخرين بدل الشعور بالرضا لان هذه
حاله تشير لعدم التوازن بين الاخذ والعطاء
كذلك تجنب الصراع او الاستسلام والموافقه
مباشره على استغلال الاخر لك بسبب عدم
الرغبه في المواجهه فتفضيل التنازل عن
القيم والاولويات والاحتياجات بدلا من
المجادله هذه اخرى وايضا محاوله ارضاء
الجميع
وعندما يصورك خوف من ان عدم تلبيه اي طلب
ربما يجعلك غير محبوب او مرفوض من
الاصدقاء
وننهي بعلامه مهمه وهي اهمال الاحتياجات
الشخصيه والشعور بانك تخشى ان ينظر اليك
على انك اناني على كل حال سالنا الناس في
الاردن كيف تقول لا لمن لا تود ان تخسر
وده او صداقته لنتابع
[موسيقى]
بحكيها بطريقه حلوه
من غير ما ازعلهم غير ما اضايقه بجيب
اسلوب كثير حلو يعني بفهمه بس مش من غير
ما احكي له لا عشان انه ما يتحسس او يزعل
ممكن اشي يعني سهل يعني اقدر اخدمه فيه
يعني ليش لا اساعده ممكن اشي كبير ما اقدر
عليه ما بقدر حسب الطلب يعني اذا كان
الطلب والله مستحيل فبدي اعتذر منه لطافه
يعني اذا كان مش مستحيل يعني بدي بطريقه
تكون حلوه هيك بكلمتين حلوات وراح يتقبل
اكيد الوضع راح يفهم وضعي وخصوصا اذا كان
صديق بصراحه اذا انا كثير هذا الشخص يعني
ما بهمني اني ما اخسره بيهمني يضل دائما
حبل الود بيني وبينه موجود بحاول بطريقه
دبلوماسيه اعبر عن رفض لهذا الطلب يعني
لازم اوضح له السبب اول اشي انه ليش انا
ما بدي هذا الشيء وبحاول اضل بيني وبينه
دائما حبل الود موجود طبعا هذا اهم شيء
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات